men don't want to change they're not  accountable for themselves they think  that because because they're a man  you're going to be attracted to them no  like you can you can't be fat you stay  at home you're just playing video games  and you expect a woman to want to [ __ ]  you no she's not going to want to [ __ ]  you yeah this is the point and and and  then she won't and Society will teach  them a lesson they might be able to pull  off a little black with a girl for a  year or so but in general they're gonna  end up lonely in general they're gonna  struggle to find Partners I agree with  you with the cosmetic surgery thing  women are happy to change out their  appearance and change how they look but  they're not happy to change how they act  most of them they're not happy